thank you for the staying for the
closing event
uh so i'm alex and i will talk to you
about community detection graphs and
some disclaimer this would be
this lecture is pure theoretical no code
at all
i prepared some uh some github
repository for you to play with graphs
and some algorithms but it's up to you
okay a few words about myself i'm a data
scientist at hunters which is a
cyber security ai israeli startup like
all the buzzwords
and we're hiring so if you want to talk
to me about grass or ai or hunters you
can
reach me
yes
uh
so some agenda for today and
i would like to expand with the
motivation and some definitions of
community detection
and then go over thoroughly
uh
two algorithms the levine and the big
club
and if you have questions asked i hope
i'll be able to answer
uh so um
community detection in general so we as
a machine learning
people would like to cluster things
and given a graph we would like to
cluster it as well like each node can be
in one group or several groups and with
overlapping communities
but
running clustering algorithms like
straightforward clustering algorithms
and
is hard right k-means won't work or
it would work but not optimal like not
well
so we'd like to use some property of the
network
uh to learn this data this clustering so
we would like to get a graph and
do something like this this is not
overlapping community but
still
and
so
it's all started all the community
detection stuff started back in 50s when
some phd students zachary was
learning was doing a phd in social
studies in social science sorry
and
he was
studying some friendship in a karate
club in his university
and what happened during his
studies of this
quarter club there was a big fight
between two members of the graph
two members of the club and the graph
splitted into two
and
what he
thought was interesting question to ask
is how can we
cut the graph by cutting the minimum
number of edges
so we can split the the graph into two
into new clubs
so this is like the first example of
how the network social network
properties can be pretty predictive
uh
there's also a shameful award for anyone
who mentions this
network in conventions this you get a
small like a word
and
what do we do with
um
community detection
uh
basically if you work with graph in one
point or another you would like to
cluster it and do a community detection
uh so in social networks you would like
to find communities of friends or untake
communities like of enemies
uh you would like to cluster customers
with similar
interest in advertising
and the third one is a really
interesting blog post from silverford
and they're talking about detecting
malicious networks using a community
detection on their graph
so there's like variety of applications
for this
uh
so what they what is what is actually
community uh if we take a look of a
group of nodes
so we can
say there are community if the links
within this group is
are larger than outside the group like
the free ones here if you see the there
are many links inside and a few outside
and the way we measure this community
this uh
the strength of this community of this
partitioning
is something that is called modularity
uh
which is calculated like this like
modularity is the queue
and we have a disjoint
group of communities this is for
non-overlapping communities
and we go over all group and we count
the number of edges within this group
and subtract the expected number of
edges
within this group that we think that
should be within this group
so we'll talk
soon about what is the expected number
but um
like ideally if we found a much bigger
number then we expect that some random
deviation of this uh
group we found the community or
anti-community if this number is
smaller
and
so uh the expected number of edges uh
how do we find it we'll define something
that is called a null model
and uh given a graph with n nodes and m
edges we would like to construct a new
graph g tag
with the same distribution and g graph
is multi-graph which means that between
two edges
between two nodes there can be few edges
and we will say that the expected number
of edges between node i and j is the
multiplication of their degrees which is
a k sub i and k sub j
divided by 2m and if you remember
anything about graph theory so this is
quite like important formula which means
that if we sum all the
degrees in graph we'll get twice the
number of edges because each edge is
counted twice
so why why is the formula correct so
if you think about it
if we
look on
edge i it has
ki spokes coming out of him
and
edge node j sorry uh has k j spokes
coming out of him so we multiply the two
like
this is the probability of them
connecting divided by
2m
and we can verify this number by
counting the number of edges in the
graph
so we'll we divided by 2 here because we
count each h twice then we sum all the
i's all the j's and this number
one divided by two m is going outside of
the equation and then we are left with
two expressions similar to this
so we get m which is actually the number
of edges so
this uh
formula is probably correct
uh
so another thing another way to think of
uh
modularity is the
the second formula the blue one
so given a graph and a subjoint
group of
of
communities
will go over all the communities and
will go over all the nodes in these
communities
and we'll
set a i j to be down the number of edges
between node i and o j
and subtract the expected number
and we um
we normalize it by 2m which means that
basically this number is between -1 and
1 right if the
if we don't expect any edges so we'll
just sum all the all the edges together
all the all the edges and we'll get one
and
the other way around we'll get minus one
uh
so modularity range between minus one
and 1
and
if it's positive it means that we
found
more edges in a community than we
expected which means we found something
significant
and as a rule of thumb uh 0.3 and 0.7
means that find some significant
community
and if the value is negative then the
number of expected edges like we found
less than expected so we found an
anti-community
a community of enemies like if we're
talking about social network so the idea
uh is to
maximize the modularity and that's how
we find the different communities and
this brings us to our first algorithm
the vein algorithm
which is called after a
university of belgium i think
and it's pretty fast it runs
in n log n which is like quick start
test
and it outputs um
a few levels of communities as we can
see in this diagram
at the first level we have only nodes at
the second level we have uh
like the the small circles of community
then we have bigger communities until we
have the old gra all graph
uh
the important thing to remember is that
it it does not provide us the optimal
answer because uh finding optimal
modularity is hard it's np hard
so it finds some optimization for this
problem
and it
runs multiple times in two phases the
first phase
and
we
try to find the optimized modularity by
doing some small changes we ask each
node if we move this node to some
neighbor community will we gain
something in the modularity and if so
we'll move it
and after we
do not have any more nodes to to move
we'll run phase two we'll aggregate
these nodes together into supernode and
do it vice like
runs run it over and over
until we converge
so visually
it looks something like this we start
with the graph
then we then identify the communities uh
like red community and blue and yellow
uh
after we find them we aggregate the
communities into four nodes because
there are four communities we sum their
edges their inside edges and their
outside edges and run this algorithm
again
yeah so you actually get a hierarchical
structure
yeah
this this is one of the coolest thing
about this algorithm that you can
you can have a few layers of communities
why do you need to do multiple passes
can you just stop after the first person
if if you want
like you you don't have
like you don't have to do the second
phase you can
do the first but like it's pretty quick
so
why not
uh
so so the partitioning part so for each
node we perform two calculation
uh
we try to put it in the communities of
its neighbors and then we find the one
that gives us the largest gain in delta
q which is like the delta modularity
and we run this part until we we don't
have anything to gain
uh
so this is quite difficult uh
formula i don't want to explain it all i
just want to explain the idea of it
the delta q when we move node i into
community c
is the
um
is this is the
subtract of the community of the
node i going into c minus its previous
value like the the modularity before and
modularity after minus the modularity
before
and
then we do
this part we we we're asking ourselves
how much we lose when we're moving node
this the same node from c to d
and delta d is there
uh
actually it should be minus there but
minus the modularity
uh and we can think of this this
calculation more easily if you think of
our graph as a three point three note
graph we have our node i the red one the
the the rest of the community and the
rest of the graph so this makes the
calculation a bit easier
uh
and phase two will we already talked
about it like we aggregate all the nodes
we sum the edges with some of the inner
edges and outer edges and we run
so basically our
output algorithm like our algorithm
looks like this we start with
each node in its own community we ask
which one will gain the most
get the first layer of communities
aggregate and so on and so on
until
we get the whole graph
this is the levain algorithm
which is cool but it works only on
non-overlapping communities which not
really like the real data right so our
our real data doesn't look like the left
graph is more like the right one we have
overlapping communities and even more
like this one
this like this is like facebook social
data of some guy
and we have his high school friends and
company and stanford squash and baseball
team
and there are a lot of overlappings and
this
these communities luvin algorithm won't
find it
so
what we will do now we'll define a new
null random
graph model which will help us to
achieve this goal
and
the new model is called affiliation
graph model agm
and we will we'll talk about this model
in a bit but the idea is given this agm
we would like it to generate a graph as
similar to our graph
and we'll take the most the the closest
one to our graph and this will represent
our communities
so the hgm looks something like this
where it's a bipartite graph
with a few parameters on one hand on the
lower side we have the nodes
on the upper side we have the
communities here we have two communities
and the
uh
blue nodes are
connected to community a and the green
into b and red into both
and we have the probability they're p a
and p b which is the probability of the
nodes
to link with each other within the
community right
and given this model we can generate a
graph
uh
which is quite easy because we take all
the nodes as is
and then we flip a coin for for the
connection which
within which it within each community
and if node belongs to a few communities
we like flip a few coins
and
we can see that this agm model is quite
flexible because it can describe a
multiple
multiple
communities
it can describe overlapping
or nested or not overlapping like the
vein
like any type of community will
will work here do you need to ask it for
uh
like how many how many communities there
are or is it
no so these these parts are the
parameters of the of the
of the model
right so the v and the c and the m and
the p they're all parameters of the of
the model
okay
so given this model it's quite easy for
us to generate a graph some graph
but it's not that interesting because we
want the other way around right right we
want given we have a graph and we want
to generate a model and that's how we
can find the communities
uh
and
let's see how we will do it so
this is how we'll do it
yeah so we would like
to get a model that generates graph
and then we will ask ourselves how close
this new generated graph g tag is close
to our graph g
and we go all
over all the models and we'll find the
best one
and this that's how we'll get an
approximation
uh as close to our graph and
describe the community get the model
that describes our graph the best
right like if you need to remember
anything from this lecture it's like
this stuff because it's real cool trick
and
for that we need to
understand how we do two things the
first thing is efficiently calculating
the probability of a graph given a model
and maximizing over g which is using
gradient descent
right this is no trick but gradient
descent
so given g and f would like to calculate
the likelihood of g generated
of f generated g
so our graph looks like this we have
zeros and ones
this is it's a gen a changing matrix
zeros represent no nodes ones represent
nodes
and our model looks like this because we
have this flip of coins right
sorry so this isn't handwritten
unweighted but i think
actually i'm not sure if it will work
with weighted i'm pretty sure it will
but
in this
in this example it's not unweighted
so we'll do something like this right
we'll
get the product of all the
probabilities of u and v in the graph in
the model
uh
and
multiplied by all the all the
probability of u and v not in the graph
like the
u and v from there
and then we'll get some
matrix and then we'll see how close it
is to our model
and
so
working with this kind of a bipartite
graph
is is hard
in order to make our life a bit easier
we'll define fua which is like a number
of the membership strength of mo of node
u to community a
and it's zero if it doesn't belong
and if we go all over over all the
communities we get a vector f u which is
like a row vector of all the memberships
uh
so
probability of node u of nodes u and v
uh
to be
for a membership is like 1 minus the
exponent of dot product of these vectors
if so if you think about it we have two
vectors we're doing dot products so we
sum
the the multiplications we get
ones or we get values
for the
for the places they both belong to
so
this is like one minutes exponent will
be a small number and it will be
proportional to the strength of the
of the membership
and
then we'll take
this uh multiplication and we'll run
we'll apply log on both sides
because uh doing
a
numeric
calculation on real small numbers quite
unstable so we do
we apply log and we'll
now we're like in log likelihood and the
multiplications become sums
so basically this this is not not really
important we will we're doing a gradient
descent and we'll select the f that
we're making small changes in f but the
idea is is to find the model that is
generate
generate graph as close to ours
and that's how we
get the affiliate the affiliation model
that describes our communities the best
and
basically that's it
uh so the first point here is my githubs
you can find the lavender algorithm
example
and
in a graph that i created you can play
with it a bit
the second is a really good lecture from
stanford which i use to make this one so
it talks about stuff like about pretty
much stuff that i talked but much more
thoroughly and the slides for this uh
lecture and the paper for big clam is
also an interesting one
so thank
you
so you define the future hilarity score
for uh this joint partition yeah yeah
did we somehow extend it to the
overlapping
uh
not then i i'm pretty sure you can i'm
not aware but i'm not like an expert in
this uh area yeah there's a lot more
algorithms these are just two examples
there are algorithms that
um
use memberships of uh of the edges and
like weird stuff like this is like
pretty basic things
uh
what kind of metadata
it's not only the connection between
them it's like maybe if they live in the
same country
uh
yeah but but then like
these methods are pretty general that
will work on any graph if you have like
more specific graph that maybe you have
like girl location or different kinds of
nodes also right if if you have
i don't know if if you're talking about
advertising networks or your products
and you have customers so then you'll
need to do adaptation to these
algorithms to your to your network
but
this probably won't work as well on the
network with different kinds of nodes
and different kinds of edges right
i think that as long as you've
try to model a similarity between those
and set that as the weight between them
rather than like the manual
yeah probably that's an interesting idea
thank you
thank you
[Applause]